good morning believe nation happy
thursday it's thursday i'm excited it's
a it's an interesting kind of sunny they
had sighs honey mix of clouds screeching
bad guys gratitude livejournal gun to
journal live stream number 39 super
pumped me back here with you guys we do
this every day right we do this every
day we talk about things that were
grateful for uh three things i'm going
to go through from my list I want you
guys and share three things in the live
chat and then people watching later
share three things down below you got to
make it consistent has to be daily and
you got to ask yourself why why is so
important to you because if you want the
emotional benefits you want to be a
happier healthier entrepreneur have a
bigger impact go chase things that you
want go make that big difference in the
world then I think gratitude to keep
part of it so it's been an important
part of my morning routine and I'm
thankful to be able to share it with you
guys as well I'm going to start off
first thing for me I had a lot of fun
interaction yesterday that I'm really
grateful for it started with I had the
seven ways video i put up a list of my
seven what i thought with a seven
greatest youtube channels for
entrepreneurs even seeing that I check
it out is fun and a couple of people who
are in the video wrote back either
commented on the video or wrote me a
message Tim Schmoyer wrote in lewis
howes wrote a comment tony robbins teams
wrote me a message how it cocked with me
a message and so it's just fun to see
people recognize and just being there
they were thankful for the recognition
so it's great to hear from them then
aight rule 10 xihua it last night he has
this thing every night on a wednesday
night where they're doing lessons from
youtubers and i was a part of the season
one and now he's doing season two and I
was in there I had a little bit of time
to kill before going to him
mean and so I was in there for about 15
minutes and first I just said hey guys
what's up in the chat I was great to see
how many of Tim's fans were also friends
of my channel had some great dialogue
there but then Tim saw one of the things
that I post and he mentioned my name so
then I wrote I wrote in live chat OMG
Tim said my name OMG in like happy faces
and then he saw it and mentioned that
instead of laughing too anyways a little
fun little fun fun moment last night uh
and then I end up staying up till two
just passed to I had a meeting with
somebody on my team from 1030 until two
so that was a intense meeting was good
meeting I might have a couple bags into
the eyes but it was a fun attraction
last night so really grateful for all
the the fun interactions people last
night hopefully some more today I've got
some meeting some calls one hanging out
later in the afternoon so here's to the
continued fun interactions with people
second thing uh Nina last night made me
a healthy snack when I was going to go
have my meeting oh I felt like I wanted
something mr. Khan something that
something to bring in so she made me a
tea but also these awesome cheese and
tomato that's made of grapes she's in
great skewers I guess I'm a toothpick so
this like smoky cheese I don't know what
it was Havarti or something and then I
grape on a toothpick and gave me a whole
bunch of those to share and sack on so
that was that was a good that was a good
snack and I'm super appreciative to Nina
for doing that and number three let me I
you know what let me see I want to say
no robots you guys are hearing me okay
looks like it no robots on the stream
for the past two days whatever that
crazy YouTube pickup was you know great
before clear broadcasts and
communications being able to get our
point across and be here with each other
so those are the three things that I
agree before I'm going to get to the
live chat now see how you guys are doing
this morning happy
Thursday zeno kicks us off again what's
up y'all what are you grateful for today
what's up y'all I feel like he's taking
that from rishi a fielder's of Rishi
influence there I don't know how many
Dutch people say y'all but might be a
new thing everyone in Harlem is now
going to y'all it up a cup of y'all
coming from from Maria Rodriguez he's
grateful for number one blister plasters
I need them and they work pretty well I
don't want a blister plaster is
something to help a blister cover a
blister anyway I'm glad that they're
working I like to happen face at the end
to a good night's sleep I wish I had
that last night bro I didn't wake up
once which is quite rare for me lately
that's super cool I wonder what the
difference was that made that happen for
you and number three being able to
handle criticism pretty well that
probably comes with being your own worst
critic everything they say they has
already passed your mind interesting I
like to thank you for sharing Xena next
J reyez thankful for fasting which
resets and rejuvenates our bodies I
haven't really gone on a big fast I
thought if you guys have done a fast
maybe like a half day fast but nothing
major maybe I should for leading-edge
architects and builders creating
gorgeous eco-friendly condos for clothes
which taste and smell delicious as well
as he'll tell a garlic clove of clove of
garlic clove of something else I guess
you don't eat a clove of garlic so it's
a clove or something else now i'm
curious what are these magical clothes
that taste so i'll say so good mm-hmm
super interesting that uh next may have
a Maha villas back welcome back my hovel
we missed you in the live chat number
one grateful for being back with you
believe nation I love it well we missed
you too bro welcome home number two
grateful for a great day overall awesome
and three
be grateful for finishing some boring
tasks boring tasks are pretty boring so
that's good i'm glad you can move on
what else what else what else we got
some chatter we got some chatter Zeno's
asking if we're going to see thunder
claps of excitement yes too bad I won't
be there for the afternoon live stream
but I'm grateful to be able to watch the
replay says they know yeah 415 I think
it is about how to build a YouTube
channel my only other well we have the
legalized from after this and then that
one's going to happen at four-fifteen
eastern a light day on the streams but a
busy day on the meeting side of things
today what do we got Rishi's in the
house switches in the house hello guys
yes I trill Tim that was funny shweta is
grateful today for YouTube it's
important i'm grateful every day for
youtube youtube has made such a big
difference both both and what I've
learned and what I've been able to share
you know what it impossible before
YouTube for that creation so yeah super
super excited new future builder
grateful to be able to wake up and live
a life where I feel safe ninety-nine
percent of the time it's pretty true you
look at what's happening around the
world a lot of people don't feel safe
they go to sleep not sure what's going
to happen so yeah I feel you there too
and I feel like they're too i love being
with v safe ninety-nine percent of the
time maybe 99.9 cuz i'm in canada yeah i
had to throw the canada love in there uh
Andrew grateful for 80 degree weather in
nashville we got through it Rishi's from
national we got Nashville in the house
here 80 degree weather natural reverb
for complete control of my mind I love
that grateful for my daily growth and
learning very cool very very cool what
else whoa it just jumped again rishi
grateful that good things happen every
day weevil for chicken the food and that
chicken the food and the youtube
personality and three believe nation
peeps I love it yes audio is great i
love it thank you guys Mitch grateful
for YouTube was it provides a free
education about autonomous cars and
consulting interested too I'm also give
up for health and three grateful for
shelter the curios grateful for snow
we're gonna get some snow pretty soon
but we don't have any yet so we'll see
and Sarah good morning grateful for
waking up this beautiful morning
grateful for social media grateful for
the next time spent with my sister this
morning very cool guys nine ten that's
it we are done thank you so much for
joining me you can hop on the twitch
chat to join in on a business q a while
we play league of legends with j rise
and rishi cupsy be otherwise i'll see
you at four fifteen later on to today in
the afternoon for an interview otherwise
a seat tomorrow morning again through
the gratitude journal live stream thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love guys see you soon